lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
practiquemos la red está usando notación
científica digamos que tengo 4.1 por 10
a la menos 2
y a esto le quiero restar 2.6 por 10
elevado a la menos 3 y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y tratan
de resolver esto por su cuenta
y suponiendo que ya lo hicieron veamos
cómo se resuelve paso a paso lo más
fácil que se me ocurre para resolver
esto es tratar de convertir uno de estos
números de manera que éste multiplicado
por la misma potencia de 10 que el otro
se me ocurre que podemos expresar este
4.1 por 10 a la menos 2 como algo que
esté multiplicado por 10 elevado a la
menos 3 por lo que tenemos 4.1 por 10 a
la menos 2 y si queremos tener este 10 a
la menos 2 como 10 a la menos 3 tenemos
que dividirlo entre 10 pero no puedo
dividir esto entre 10 así nada más
porque si ya que cambiaría el valor del
número y para no cambiar esto también
tengo que multiplicar por diez así que
multiplicamos por 10 y dividimos entre
10 y esto lo puedo escribir así 10 entre
10 por esto de aquí y tomamos 10 por 4.1
nos queda 41 y 10 elevado a la menos 2
dividido entre 10 va a ser igual a 10 a
la menos 3
esto es igual a 10 por 4.1 41 por 10 a
la menos atrás y eso tiene sentido 41
milésimas
es lo mismo que 4.1 centésimas lo único
que hicimos fue multiplicar esto por 10
y dividir esto otro entre 10 y ahora
podemos reescribir esto como 41 por 10 a
la menos 3
- 2.6 por 10 a la menos 3 y ahora
tenemos 41 por 10 al menos 3 menos 2.6
por 10 a la menos 3 por lo que esto va a
ser igual que
41 2.6 por 10 a la menos 3 tenemos 10 a
la menos 3 aquí y 10 a la menos 3 acá
una forma de ver esto es que factor
izamos este 10 a la menos 3 ahora cuento
es 41 menos 2.6 41 menos 12 39 menos 2.6
va a ser 38.4 y esto lo multiplicamos
por 10 al menos 3 y esta es la
diferencia entre estos dos números pero
ya no está en notación científica para
tener una cantidad connotación
científica
este número de acá tiene que ser mayor o
igual a 1 y menor que 10 y lo que
podemos hacer es dividir este número de
acá entre 10 es decir lo opuesto de lo
que hicimos acá arriba dividimos entre
10 y multiplicamos por 10 si
multiplicamos por 10 y dividimos entre
10 no vamos a modificar el valor del
número 38.4 entre 10 es 3.84 y 10 a la
menos 3 por 10 va a ser igual a 10 a la
menos 2 por lo que nuestro resultado es
3.84 por 10 a la menos 2